Felly rydw i'n ymwneud yn y botwm ffon ac rydw i'n rhoi £0.20 yn ymwneud ac rydw i'n ffon fy ffrind, ac mae'n cymryd.
Felly rydw i'n rhoi £0.50 yn ymwneud.
Ac roedden ni'n mynd i ddweud.
Rydw i'n teimlo'r ddau yn ôl i mi.
Rydw i'n mynd i ddweud.
Rydw i'n teimlo'r ddau yn ôl i'r botwm ffon ac rydw i'n gweld ychwanegu'r ddau.
Yn ystod y tu allan, roeddwn i'n byw ar y fflat fy ffrind.
Roedd hi'n byw ar y camys Unedig yn y Cynulliad Cymru.
Roedd hi'n byw ar gyfer gwaith ac roedd hi wedi rhoi'r llwybr i'n fflat,
allwn i'n byw ar y camys Unedig,
unrhyw lle yn Hansworth Ward,
ond pan oeddwn i'n byw ar y fflat yn y Llyfrgell,
roeddwn i'n dechrau bod yn sianol i'n mynd i'n mynd i hefyd.
Roeddwn i'n byw ym mhob.
Roeddwn i'n byw ym mhob, roeddwn i'n byw yn y ddau,
ac roeddwn i'n byw ar fy mhob.
Oherwydd o'r hyn, roedd y ffordd yn fy holl ddweud,
dweud dweud dweud,
ond rwy'n gwybod i dweud.
Ac un o'r ffordd, roedd y ffordd dweud dweud,
dweud dweud dweud.
Now to tell you the truth,
I wasn't really sure what to make of this voice.
It made me quite anxious,
but I couldn't quite figure out what it meant
or what could possibly happen.
And I had to think about it for a while.
And eventually I decided,
no, I'm going to go home.
But to appease this voice in my head,
I decided to remove my jewellery, my watch,
leave my cards behind and my cash,
but just take enough money for my bus fare there
and to return the following morning
and enough also to phone my boyfriend
from the payphone on campus.
And so I set off.
And it was probably about, I don't know,
8.30 in the evening.
So I was studying in Birmingham
and their subways, particularly when I was there,
had a reputation for being quite seedy and unsafe.
And I had actually been flashed at
a number of times down there.
But on this particular occasion,
as I walked through the tunnel,
I noticed a female police officer ahead of me.
And I remember thinking this was a good omen.
I kind of broke my stride
so we were almost walking in tandem
without making it too obvious.
And then I exit the subway
and I get to my bus stop.
And usually, regardless of what the timetable says,
I always have to wait half an hour for my bus.
But on this particular evening,
it comes within minutes.
So when I get on the bus,
I actually sit near the bus driver
because I think this is the most sensible thing to do.
And then I arrive at my stop.
And at this point, I'd say,
I'm pretty much on the home stretch.
All I have to do now is get home.
And as I'm walking along the street,
I suddenly notice an empty phone box on the corner.
And in that moment, I decide,
I'm going to call my boyfriend from there.
Now, I make this decision
because the payphone on my campus serves about 50 people
and it's always ringing off the hook.
So if I really want to speak to my boyfriend tonight,
this is my best chance.
I realise at this point,
I'm slightly deviating from the plan
of just going straight home.
But I can distinctly remember
as I felt the door close behind me.
I'm safe in here.
It's a box.
So I put my money in and I call my boyfriend.
And then suddenly, I feel the door behind me open.
A hand appears out of nowhere
and I watch it press down the switch hook of the phone.
I hear the pound coin drop to the bottom
and I watch this hand remove the coin.
I don't remember dropping the receiver,
but I do remember seeing it swing from side to side.
Suddenly, these arms tighten around me
and I can feel something sharp against my neck.
And I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
My mouth is dry and I can hardly breathe
and my heart is beating so fast,
I can feel it pulsing in the back of my throat
like at any moment it could just rip through.
And I'm fighting so hard to stop my knees from buckling.
And I keep saying to myself over and over again,
is this happening?
This isn't happening.
Is this really happening?
I think I'm told not to move or make a sound,
but I can't be sure.
He asks me for money, but I don't have any.
No, wait, I do.
I have 75 pence.
I think he thinks I'm mocking him,
so I give him my bag and he turns me around
and he pushes me up against the phone.
And through the sheer panic of it all,
something happened to me.
I was suddenly overcome by this strange sense
of calm, presence and lucidity.
My senses were heightened
and I could feel and sense everything around me.
It was like I was inhabiting every cell of my body
and I think time must have stood still or something
because after that everything happened in slow motion.
The voice in my head asks me,
so how does this end?
What happens now?
And so I start running through all these different scenarios
in my mind.
Or maybe I'm stabbed and I die.
Or maybe I'm raped, stabbed and then I die.
Or maybe, maybe I'm stabbed,
but I go into intensive care,
but then I slip into a coma and then I die.
And the voice says,
well, whatever way you look at this,
you really have nothing to lose.
But if you do survive, the police will want a description.
You need to get a description.
So I slowly raise my hands and I turn around to face him.
And I tell him to check my pockets for money
just in case he doesn't believe me.
And as he does, I look at him
and I take the image of him in.
The colour of his hair, his eyes,
his clothing, his height,
and the Stanley knife in his hand.
He looks up and he notices the tracking movements of my eyes
and he quickly turns me around
and he forces me up against the phone.
His hands start to move over my breasts.
And the voice says, don't move.
Don't even flinch.
Let him touch you.
Let him think he has you.
And so I do.
Let him touch me.
And for a brief moment,
I can almost sense a slight release of tension in his arm.
And all the while, I kept thinking to myself,
how did I get into the phone box?
Which way did the door open?
What side of the door was the handle on?
Which hand did I use?
Meanwhile, his hands are travelling downwards
towards my groin.
And in that moment, I decide,
I'd rather die.
I grab his arms and I use my weight
to push him backwards into the door.
And using my elbows, I swing to the right
so that as I swing to the left,
I use his weight to leverage the door open.
And the door opens and so I run.
And I'm screaming, I think.
But then I stop running
because I realise very quickly
he's not chasing me.
He's run away.
I don't know what it was in that moment
if it was just the effects of the adrenaline.
But all I wanted to do was find him
so that I could stab him and kill him.
But as I'm looking around, I don't see anyone,
apart from an Indian man standing in the driveway
of his house next to his car.
He shouts to me, are you okay?
Of course I'm not okay, I've just been mugged.
Which way did he go?
I start running down a dark road
and the man chases me and brings me back,
telling me it's not a good idea.
He walks me to the phone box
where I pick up my bag and I replace the handset.
And the phone rings.
And so, for some bizarre reason, I answer it.
It's my boyfriend.
He tells me he's been trying to call me
for the last two minutes.
What?
Are you sure?
I hang up and then the Indian man offers to drive me home.
I tell him he's crazy, I'm not getting in a car with you.
You're a stranger, you're a man.
He offers to bring his wife along so that I feel safe.
It's just that now I have to wait for her
because she has to get ready and get her purse.
So as I stand outside the door,
waiting for her,
every single member of the family appears at the door
wanting to know what happened,
wanting to come along for the ride.
Eventually, everyone is seated in the car.
Everyone except for me.
There's no room for me to sit.
Someone has to get out of the car
so that I can get in, so that I can go home.
Eventually, it's agreed that the grandfather will stay behind.
The drive is excruciatingly slow
owing to the weight of the car and so claustrophobic.
I burst into tears and the grandmother says,
stop crying, what are you crying for?
It's not like you were raped.
Oh, wait a minute, she says.
He didn't touch you down there, did he?
No?
Well, that's all right then
because otherwise you would have been spoiled.
We get to the car park and I ask to be let down.
They offer to walk me to my door and I flat out refuse.
As I watch the car pull away,
I realise as I stand in this dark car park,
I'm breathing again.
It's only in that moment I realise I'm home.
I made it home.
Thank you.